uh your business venture so this
you fighting has also opened up a lot of
different opportunities for you you now
have businesses hot sauce you got
charities can you talk about what some
of the projects you're working on today
yeah the hot sauce i love cooking
and always wanted to have some space in
the culinary world and during the last
year during the pandemic when we were at
the beginning of like march you know we
were locked in the house
that's when i started putting pen to
paper and jotting down ideas and and
finding people who i can link up with
who were respected in that industry and
we put it together and and we launched
it um
january of this year
and it's doing very well man
the the hot sauce yeah i got a bunch of
mod office by the way yeah yeah yeah we
got the hot sauce that's great yeah yeah
so hot sauce is purely because you're
cooking yeah i'm cooking i love to cook
but i'm also from louisiana and we take
our hot sauce serious in louisiana yes
it's like a religion over there yeah
louisiana hot sauce is a special thing
and i wanted and i was just home and
during the pandemic and saw an
opportunity to
get in the culinary world
dustin how much does
does you
winning in your world that you're in
in the in the
ufc mma world that you're in how much
does this
create additional opportunities for you
outside of the world how much have you
seen that happen it's huge
you know because i'm already have a
spotlight with these fights and the
build up with these fights
and
for hot sauce
guys eating wings watching fights the
demographic that's following the sport
and and my fan base it was just a great
timing and a great thing
it was a i knew it was going to be a win
from the jump
and my star in the ufc not only raises
that with the sales of the hot sauce but
it also gives me a platform to speak
about my charity and to speak about the
things we're working on
and i want to take advantage of that you
know and when the ufc moved over to espn
i was excited because i knew that just
i had a bigger megaphone now to get
these goals with my charity out
but definitely me fighting has created
opportunities no doubt about it
do you think if you would have tried to
do the hot sauce and the charity
when you're not in the top five or the
top ten it would have the same impact as
it does today do you think there was an
element of timing like let's wait to do
this when we got a bigger platform and
then let's launch it yeah
i i really believe that
at this time you know i'm fighting in
the biggest fights of the year all eyes
are on me so i really have an
opportunity to
take advantage of that and and so many
more people are hearing the news about
what we're doing with charity or hearing
the news about the hot sauce just way
more eyes on me and what i have going on
yeah it's very big because a lot of
times guys will you know try to do
everything at the same time too early
before they're way too big
and then you you don't have that big of
a impact right because you can't you
don't have the eyeballs on you yet
rather than let me go win here first and
then i can do the all the other you know
ancillary whatever additional things
that i want to do and sometimes these
become bigger than this yeah yeah so
looks like that's that was kind of your
strategy yeah i just it was a perfect
timing like you said perfect timing my
charity
me and my wife lived in florida here in
boca raton for five years and then my
daughter was born we moved back to
louisiana because i wanted to raise her
with family
but um
when we were moving i had these drawers
full of fight worn gear over the years
of fights like my first win in the ufc
my first win in the wec fights that just
meant these these
these things just meant something to me
and it's cool when you have one or two
or three
but when you have 40 something fights
and your drawers are just full of bloody
gloves and clothes it's not cool anymore
it's kind of gross and we were moving
and packing up a u-haul and we're like
what are we going to do with all this
stuff and we were just thinking talking
and we decided to auction some stuff off
and donate the money to a fallen officer
who had just passed away in the line of
duty right near where my wife and i went
to school in louisiana so we did that
and then we did it again did it a few
more times
and i was just doing that out of my name
like dustin donates some money dustin
does it and i was in training camp one
one day and we were talking and we
wanted to see if we can give it its own
identity and
turn this into an actual charity so it's
not dustin does this dustin does that we
can turn it into something that has its
own name and see if it can grow
organically and other people can get
behind it and my goal was to have other
fighters donate their fight war
memorabilia and we can auction it off or
sell it and do things in their
communities too
and we started the good fight foundation
and since then we've done some amazing
things i'm very proud of we're currently
building housing in uganda right now for
the pygmy people
we teamed up with manny pacquiao for
that goal also justin wren as well yeah
so that and we don't have one specific
goal we do all we do all kinds of things
whatever we see we can help in the in
the community or
wherever
it's a good fight foundation and that's
your 501c3 that's my favorite awesome
and also i have no no background in
starting a business or building a
website so me and my wife are in
training camp um on a laptop computer
trying to build this website for the
foundation we're just starting and
it's been a learning thing man you know
we we was running like a mom-and-pop
shop at the beginning
but it's it's cool because
we have full control of everything we
have still no paid uh no payroll we
haven't paid anybody there's no no
employees of the foundation it's just me
my wife two of our friends from
louisiana and and we're doing some
amazing things i'm very proud of so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]